If I start a round of Artemisidin, would that help with bone metastatic cancer from lymphoma and what happens and how often?
So Artemisidin is an herb that's also called wormwood.
There's different varieties, but typically it's Artemisidin audioa that is the herb that's used.
And it can be good for cancer.
Most of the studies on Artemisidin have been for viral infections and a lot of studies for malaria.
So Artemisidin, you're really, I told you story before, but it just makes me mad and sad, but I think about it.
But Artemisidin is actually a wonderful killer of malaria.
And it actually is an herb, but it grows like a shrub.
And it is native to a lot of areas.
And one of the areas native to is Africa and understanding it, Africa.
The number one cause of death in Africa is malaria.
Well, there's a wonderful drug that the pharmaceutical companies have put out to take care of malaria.
So if you go over to Africa, you could take a malaria medication with you and you won't die of malaria.
It's a wonderful drug. The problem is the cost of one dollar a day.
Well, what's a big deal with dollar a day? That's nothing.
Well, to somebody in Africa dollar a day, they're literally, you know, the average person in a lot of countries in Africa may be making a dollar a day.
And they have four kids or 10 kids or something. I can't treat their whole family.
So that's hence the leading cause of death in Africa.
Well, why don't they use Artemisidin? Well, truth is, about 15 years ago, the pharmaceutical companies systematically paid people to burn Artemisidin forests.
And they destroyed Artemisidin shrubs in the majority of Africa.
That is a true story. That is sick, sad and unbelievable because they wanted to sell their drug.
So I know of two humanitarian groups that are their mission is to reproduce Artemisidin forests in Africa and they teach people how we use it.
So it's pretty cool.
But Artemisidin is a great thing for cancer, too. So it's not just for malaria. It can be really good for different viruses. It can be good for different infections, but it can also be really good for cancer.
This little slide that shows what it does. It decreases chronic inflammation and bad inflammation.
It's a decrease or a bit or look at six, interleukin 1B, T and a falfa, and a capabata.
And a capabata is one of the one of the very destructive inflammatory markers with cancer.
Interleukin 6 is a destructive inflammatory marker with bowl loss. So it would be, so in that sense, the question is, would Artemisidin be good for metastatic cancer?
Artemisidin can be good for any cancer. But the only reason why I would say I haven't seen specific studies and say it's good for metastatic bone cancer in a sense, except that it decreases interleukin 6.
This one right here, IL-6, interleukin 6 is highly elevated, whatever there's bone loss. So not just with metastatic cancer to the bone, but also with osteoporosis.
So osteoporosis is an inflammatory disease, because you have a lack of calcium. So it's because you have an inflammatory disorder to the bones with a highly elevated interleukin 6.
Now, there is one thing that is better than Artemisidin to decrease interleukin 6, and it's EGCG from green tea extract.
So the tea-vego product from US enzymes would do even a better job than Artemisidin to decrease interleukin 6 at the bone.
But you can certainly feel that Artemisidin can be good for cancer in general.
So, you know, it's a great product to take. Now, understand why don't you recommend that to everybody? Well, there's a ton of great products and sake. And I think, you know, I don't want everybody to be on an overload of products that they're taking.
Yeah, the Artemisidin that I would say to use, I'm going to find it here. I'll pull it up and show it to you.
Is this one right here called Artemisidin Solo by research nutritionals. And I would take two to three of these a day.
This, I think, is the better. The best Artemisidin on the market right now.
And I've been using Artemisidin for decades because Artemisidin personally, I don't take Artemisidin currently, but I've been using it a lot with Lyme disease because it's one of the great, you know, hidden Lyme disease killer. So Artemisid can be a real benefit from that.
But it can be another thing you can use for cancer. I am, you know, in the cheek swap testing. I have a number of people that might even be on this call that are taking and I recommend to miss it.
But it can be something that anybody can add. So, can you take the Artemisidin with TV? Oh, yes. Yeah.
We work on a little bit different pathways, but they both do decrease that into root of six by AFP is still elevated still in the 10 to 14 range when it should be below six any thoughts on why none of my doctors know why is it possible that 10 to 14 is by normal range.
So, this person has had surgery AFP is a trigger marker.
And they're wondering why debugging the cancer didn't decrease a lot of things, but not their AMP.
So, why does a tumor marker not go down when you debug the cancer? There may even be no evidence of disease anywhere, but the tumor marker is still elevated.
So, remember, these are different proteins that are in the blood.
So, does it, does it always mean if you have an elevated tumor marker that you have, you have some sort of cancer? The answer is no.
So, a matter of fact, there is a normal range. So, AFP normal range should be below six. That means five would be within normal range in a person could not have cancer and still have five because it's not just made these things are not just made by tumors.
And there may be an up regulation of other cells that are making these proteins after post cancer.
So, it could be a neurological up regulation of other cells that are making this protein. And it's not just AFP, any of the tumor markers.
So, two markers are just, it's remembered, like any test, it's just one test that is a possible indicator of something going on. So, you weigh that test out with comparing with other tests and other signs and symptoms.
So, different objective tests and different subjective signs and symptoms, you weigh that all out. Could your range just be normally high? Well, it could, how would we know that? Well, there's no way we could, unless we could jump at our time machine and go back to pre-cancer days and run an AFP and see if it is elevated then.
But even that, it could literally have been what I first described that because you had cancer, you have an up regulation of production of AMP of other cells too. So, you're just making more of it.
Could it be that I am hidden cancer somewhere that's not fun? Could be, you just don't know, you want to do other tests, you don't rely on just one test, you don't, you just don't, you just look at other signs and symptoms.
You could have something that's, that's, that's, that's increasing that has nothing to do with kids. When I sent my cheek swab, you suggested a few additions and increased a couple of the supplements you recommend. Does that mean I stay on all the others? Yes.
So, I'm just giving you the changes in that cheek swab test. Yes. I don't know if you evaluated everything on the spreadsheet that I sent. Yes, I did.
Including those from another practitioner. Yes, as best I could, I didn't have, I don't have all those. So, I don't, I, I did as best as I could.